bonjour à tous les biens dans ce nouvel
épisode de 1h sur internet alors le
premier que j'avais fait c'était en
février dernier donc c'était assez
longtemps mais j'avais pas pu le pot des
deux nouvelles vidéos sur cette chaîne
maintenant que c'est chose faite je
reviens avec ce format qui vous a plu
cet épisode il a un petit peu
particulier parce qu'il était en
partenariat avec you démis donc un site
de cours et de formation en ligne vous
en reparler à la fin de la vidéo
mais en attendant je propose qu'on se
perdre ensemble une heure sur internet
pas vraiment une avant je prendrai les
meilleurs moments parce que sinon ça
d'être extrêmement relou et j'espère que
ça va être intéressant
je commence toujours par twitter parce
que je commençais le coeur névralgique
[Musique]
ses impressions ses remarques sur ninja
donc le streamer de fortes ait le plus
connu au monde qui est le mieux payé au
monde qui a passé leur 3800 heures cette
année ait a fait donc c'est l'équivalent
de 95 semaine de 40 heures vu qu'il a
expliqué en mars qui faisait 500 mille
dollars par mois ça fait que par heure
il fait 1477 vague de 54 au dollar
pendant six chez 1477 par heure a donc
par minute
si je divise par seconde avec 40 cents
dire que si le mec fait tomber une pièce
de 50 cents par terre le temps qui se
penche et qui la ramasse et en fait s'il
avait joué au jeu vidéo par fortnight et
se serait fait plus de tout alors ça
c'est assez style c'est une photo de
tâches hassoun harkis et leur animatrice
chez pixar est donc elle table sur mille
et une pâtes
du coup elle a aimé un poussin vivant
pour étudier sa manière de marcher de
bouger et c'est pour travailler sur ces
animations le temps de d'amener le
poussin au taf ninja le ridja gagner son
salaire jean gratos david hasselhoff à
côté de lui même
sir jay hill se caresse de manière très
chaud l'eau je pense que vous avez
marqué énorme énorme de peur des
araignées qui donne du blé alors sa
coque potentiellement si on veut arrêter
le lait de vache
on peut faire des fermes d'araignée
potentiellement j'aime pas ça se
consomme pour les jours auxquels on fait
le lait a été analysé et genre il a du
sucre il à la grèce il a quatre fois
plus de protéines que le lait de vache
gens c'est du les pauvres les gens bien
trop stylé on apprend quand même des
choses je sais un article super
intéressant dit hollywood reporter qui
parle des résidences permet en
californie notamment à los angeles et
qui le met en perspective avec les feux
donc il ya eu plein d' incendies en
californie vous avez dû sûrement voir
des images qui sont enfin bref
terrifiante et c à c ur parce qu'en fait
mon les résidences fermées
c'est très fréquent aux états unis mais
là ils sont en train de parler de faire
un mur de près de deux mètres de haut
qui retarde le feu ok mais surtout
l'option d'avoir des pompiers genre
privé c'est ouf je vous c'est
intéressant parce que ça nous montre
aussi ce que le réchauffement climatique
peut avoir comme impact et qu'on n'avait
pas prévu quoi je n'aurais jamais
imaginé un service de pompiers privé
évidemment ce n'est pas surprenant non
plus je prends plein de juger ça je
trouve ça juste intéressant à observer
ça c'est une bonne busby à la chaux est
la plus petite du monde mais si je
reviens jouer sur les feux de 1 sur les
pompiers la privée en fait ce qui est
marrant c'est que tu as ce genre si
c'était des flics privé ça m'aurait
moins interpellé chance va quitter
twitter avec les 100 plus grandes
innovations 2018 sans innovation mais y
en at il une seule qui est en train de
changer d'avis
et ouais mon gars airbus et ibm ils ont
créé une intelligence artificielle avec
une gueule de merde vraiment qui
s'appelle simon avec un c'est nul
ok vous n'êtes pas prêt je suis tombé
sur l'innovation de 2018 jeu j'en ai
jamais entendu parler ne comprends pas
pourquoi les gens ne sont pas au courant
je vais changer votre vie il existe des
post-it extrême cd possible à coller
dans les conditions les plus extrêmes
qui fait ça genre tu des chefs de
chantier tu n'utilises pas des post-it
quoi j'ai besoin d'un truc durable a
pour édicter ce tuyau un truc qui va
tenir des années michel doré pas un post
it
non personne non personne ne fait ça
nous en donne quoi cet exemple qui t'ont
twitter j'ai mis trois jeunes et
quelques news de côté à voilà ça c'est
un truc que j'ai retrouvé je voulais
vous en parler je vais même vous faire
une vidéo là dessus a la base je vous à
sancerre très bien dans ce format est un
mec qui s'appelle robin burns qui a fait
un réseau neuronal forme d'intelligence
artificielle on va en reparler plus tard
et ce réseau neuronal il a généré des
peintures le mec qui n'a mis ça gratos
sur internet voilà parce que le mec il
est comme incident n 3 et ensuite le mec
qui nous met cette image là en fait
cette image là elle est peut-être que
vous la connaissez
mais elle est hyper importante dans le
monde de la technologie et de la mission
deux sujets qui me plaisent beaucoup
pas si vous avez vu j'ai fait un tel x
sur le sujet d'ailleurs
bio elle a marqué le monde de l'art est
dans l'intelligence artificielle parce
que en fait ce portrait qui a été
générée par l'intelligence artificielle
s'est vendue en enchères christie's pour
la modique somme de 430 2500 dollars c
est non donc c'était énormément relayé
etc mais il ya un truc que beaucoup de
gens ne relaie pas et beaucoup de gens
ne savent pas c'est que ce fameux robbie
bach est un bon repas et donc qui a fait
ces images là mais en fait il dit les
galas genre vous avez utilisé mon taf
que j'ai mis sur github une plateforme
de partage open source et tout pour les
algorithmes ou les programmes vous avez
utilisé mon programme vous en a fait
autant que tu es genre ces normes les
âges aux personnes et tout va mieux
alors le collectif d'artistes qui a
vendu la peinture ces trois français yes
donc moi ce trade il m'a fait beaucoup
de peine parce que vos habits parait-il
a dit ouais j'essaie de tourner sa
manière positive
ils repartent en flèche son code en
disant voilà si quelqu'un veut se faire
dix mille balles à partir de mon travail
c'est le bon moment et partagent un
trade ou à un des membres du collectif
d'artistes qui parle de son modèle à lui
enfin du modèle donc de rugby en
demandant de l'aide et ses abords voilà
pour faire marcher paf histoire allait à
séoul et jeunes devant un truc que
j'avais pas vu en fait
en fait il ya obvious donc le cru le
collectif qui montre une vidéo de
commencer fait leurs algorithmes et dont
il montre une nice une discussion qu'il
a eue avec moby en disant voilà on a
utilisé une partie de ton code est ce
que c'est ok pour toi
ça dérange pas et obéré ouais pas de
souci je sens qu'on sent hockey n'a même
pas besoin de me créditer quoi que ce
soit et mobiles répond ouais
effectivement mais quand j'ai vu que
vous avez commencé à mettre les
premières images en banque
là je vous ai demandé de me créditer au
gip avant quoi en penser
je trouve ça horrible dans la situation
de robbie et en même temps les trois
français je pourrais pas dire qu'ils ont
fait un truc de mal quoi bref voilà
c'est un fred que je voulais vous
partager parce que je trouve cette
histoire assez incroyable et
passionnante quoi j'ai pas vu que le
trait de continue comment ils sont
traités de voleurs et un gars qui répond
quand tu postes un code sur github
et quelqu'un d'autre le prend à eux
enfin quelque chose et le vendre
personne n'a rien volé moi je trouve ça
un débat éthique super intéressant je
suis curieux d'avoir votre avis dans les
commentaires n'hésitez pas à me les
donner mais cet exemple c'est le parfait
pont à un autre exemplaire et aussi ce
truc là que je m'étais garder pour vous
montrer c'est le premier présentateur
une intelligence artificielle en anglais
c'est avec ligne une boîte chinoise
qu'est-ce que je pense quand les nerfs
et c'est une fille cimecom c'est
flippant et ça tombe bien parce que ces
sujets d'intelligence artificielle
moi j'ai trouvé passionnant et c'est là
où je fais le point avec les vieux
démons en fait quand rue des minimes ont
contacté en mode
ouais on a rien que tu fasses une vidéo
de nous et c'est donc j'avais sur leur
site juste qui proposait un terrain sur
leurs cours en français et y avait un
cours sur le type learning et
l'intelligence artificielle que j'ai
trouvé qu'ils avaient l'air cool donc
voit carrément affalé sur les demis à
puce comme ça je vous montrais tac
voilà c'est là où j'en étais à la fois
que j'ai écouté le court que tout
dashboard voilà donc ça c'est un cours
sur le dip learning en français cinq
courts qui t'apprend à faire en pratique
à côté en pratique un réseau neuronal
alors que tu pars de zéro que j'en mange
parti de zéro et donc voilà je commence
à faire mes premiers bouts de code
réseau neuronal déjà je comprends
parfaitement maintenant est ce que c'est
le dip learning et du coup quand même on
proposait moi je suis dit vas-y c'est
super cool et un peu je crois que le
cours genre alors le prix le prix base
est assez élevé mais je les ai toujours
vu en réduction et quand je leur ai
demandé mais attendez est ce que le prix
il y aura des promotions que c'est parce
que c'est important pour moi que vous
ayez un truc accessible qui m'ont dit
oui voilà donc je crois qu'il est à 20
bat je dis peut-être n'importe quoi
c'est un peu plus peut-être un peu moins
et chante que pour ce prix là être
formés en des plannings et savoir-faire
des réseaux neuronaux et tout souffre
sachant qu'en plus à des échanges
possibles avec le prof etc moi je sais
qu'à un moment pour installer python
donc le truc pour coder etc alors j'ai
vu qu' il ya des mecs qui galèrent avec
leurs installations y poser des
questions le gard répondait etc
enfin voilà alors il ya plein de cours
surtout j'aimerais dire tout et
n'importe quoi c'est ça les réductions
dont vous parlez à la vie de ma mère
j'ai rien fait par ces réductions
donc si je les ai sais que vous les
aurez aussi est ce que j'ai kiffé c'est
qu'il ya des cours aussi au genre c'est
vraiment juste comme une master class
cola par exemple il ya un cours sur
l'autisme introduction les découvertes
ou en gros va y avoir plein de partie en
fait autour de l'autisme
voilà moi j'ai laissé pour envoyer vers
le court du clip learning mais y'a plein
de quoi voilà c'est la fin de cet
épisode de 1h sur internet
j'espère que ça vous a plu j'espère que
vous aimez ce format moi j'aime bien
faire en plus un format qui est très
pratique pour moi parce que je peux le
faire de n'importe où sur la par exemple
je suis pas chez moi je suis pas en
france et bah c'est très pratique
ça me permet parfois de vous parler de
petites choses ou genre je pourrais pas
ouvert une vidéo en entier dessus mais
pourtant jean-louis de vous en parler
parce que je trouve ça intéressant
un gros merci aussi à éluder me pour ce
partenariat
voilà donc je vous invite encore une
fois à l'échec et le court si ça vous
plaît vous savez à quel point
l'apprentissage de manière générale me
tient à coeur c'est aussi pour ça que
j'ai fait l'an tissage par exemple on se
revoit la semaine prochaine love peace
chao et non je n'ai pas utilisé son
verre
[Musique]